I've got Robert Pattinson you know him
from Twilight well he's been declared
the world's most handsome man this is a
scientific study apparently right this
is a scientific study that backs us up
Anthony because scientists have adapted
a formula that they call the golden
ratio ratio of beauty to explain this
means a person what makes a person
beautiful the golden ratio measures your
eyebrows your eyes your jaw your nose
and your lips depends on how it all
lines up on your face
Pattinson apparently came the closest to
the ancient Greeks idea of perfection
eaters Elba also by the way was in the
top ten totally get that
so it was Ryan Gosling when it comes to
women you know who was in the list who's
the winner Beyonce Queen Bee there's no
disputing that
I think Queen Bee and what do you laugh
at Brandon are you laughing at the Queen
Queen there may be a dispute is our
social director over there and yeah I
heard her laugh okay Beyonce and Bella
Hadid okay that makes sense to me
give me argument there for me well the
world knows I on this off this study as
well but no if you have a way to go but
there you are rid the most that's are
they considered him being we need to let
them know about you he could have been a
contender